problem 15 they have a square looks like
ice crown enough it's a square just yet
and they have a triangle that comes off
of the square like this not close enough
and what do they tell us they tell us
that this is 90 degrees this is 60
degrees and this is a B C D and E what
does it say and the figure above e BCD
is a square okay and AE is equal to 8
what is the area of e of EB C D so we
just have to figure out one side of the
square and it's a square so all the
sides are equal and then we're done and
this is actually just a 30-60-90
triangle problem how do I know it cuz
this angle is 60 this is 90 so this one
has to be 30 right cuz they add up to
180 and if you don't even remember what
a 30-60-90 triangle were they add up you
could go back to page 838 and they tell
you if you look at you know the middle
of that page they have special right
triangles and they tell you I'm you know
that if the hypotenuse is 2x
if the hypotenuse is 2x that the side
opposite the 30-degree side is X and
then the side opposite the 60-degree
side is X square root of 3 right so if X
is equal to 8 what's X square root of 3
X square root of 3 is going to be equal
to 8 square roots of 3 and of course
this side will be 2 times 8 which is 16
I always think that the 30-degree side
is 1/2 of the hypotenuse and then the
60-degree side is square root of 3 times
the 30-degree side that's how I think
about it but you can just look at that
at what they do on page 838 and you'll
know this is if this is 2x the side
opposite the 30-degree side is X and the
side opposite the 60-degree side is x
times square root of 3 so this has to be
8 times the square root of 3 if this
side is a square root of x squared of 3
so then as so is this side and so to
figure out the area of the square you
just say 8 times the square root of 3
times 8 times the square root of 3 and
was that equal that's 8 times 8 that's
64 times
the square root of three squared and
what's the square root of three squared
that's that's just three so become
sixty-four times three and that's what
180 plus twelve that's equal to 192 next
problem
it's really good to become become
comfortable with 30-60-90 triangles you
probably get one or two extra problems
on the SAT if you get really proficient
to that and a mixture of peanuts and
cashews the ratio by weight of peanuts
to cashews is five to do peanuts to
cashews and that's really the weight is
five to two
how many pounds of cashews will there be
in four pounds of this mixture how many
pounds of cashews
they'll be in four pounds of this
mixture so we know that cashews plus
peanuts is going to be four pounds and
we also know I could you know multiply
both sides of this equation by see this
top one but also that peanuts is gonna
are gonna be five halves the number of
cashews right because the rate the
weight of peanuts to cashews is five to
two so penis is gonna be five halves
cashews and the cashews plus the peanuts
is equal to four so we can why don't we
just substitute why don't we just
substitute this and for this so we get
cashews plus five halves of cashews is
equal to four and what is this equal to
this is equal to common denominator to
this is like one cashew right so that's
2 over 2 plus five over two cashews is
equal to four so going up here that's
seven over two kind of cashews is equal
to the four let's multiply both sides of
this times two so then you get seven
cashews is equal to eight divide both
sides by seven you get cashews is equal
to eight seven pounds how many how many
pounds all right eight seven pounds so
one in 1/7 pound
one in 1/7 pounds is gonna catch it
tonight and the step here I could have
just multiplied both sides by 2/7 times
two sevens two sevens this would have
cancelled out and I would have gotten
the same thing eight seven so there are
eight seven pounds of cashews here
next problem kind of an odd number but I
think there yeah on these free answer
they sometimes give you problems that
might have not the most clean numbers
just to trip you up okay so that's why
axis that's my x-axis this problem and
the next I will go to bed y-axis and
they drew a line here something like
that they call that line L line L they
draw another line like this they say
this is it whoops this is a this is B
and they said at this point right here
is the point 8 comma 3 okay line M not
shown passes through the origin that's
oh and intersects a B between a and B
what is one possible value of the slope
of line M so line M intersects is the
origin and intersects this line
someplace it's going to look something
like this so the whole issue here is
that this line is going to have a lower
slope than this line then line L so what
is the slope of line L what it goes
through the point 8 comma 3 and it also
goes to the point 0 comma 0 so what's
the slope of line L change in Y over
change in X change in Y over change in X
3 minus 0 3 minus 0 over 8 minus 0 0 is
equal to 3/8 right so this slope is 3/8
so in order for this slope has to be
less than this and it's also going to be
greater than 1 right because it's still
in the first quadrant so it's still
going to be in this range so what's the
slope that's less than 3/8 and greater
than
well I don't know to 8 which equals 1/4
that would work that's less than 3/8 and
greater than 1 I mean you could say I
don't know you could say 1/8 that would
work 1/16 would work 1 1000 will work
any of those that's all possible values
for the slope of M because they just say
it intersects a be between a and B it
doesn't say you know where so any any
line you know it could look like this
it could be the line could look really
small so that would be like a slope of 1
over a thousand but it would still work
next problem problem 18 whoops problem
18 ok so they gave us a table so they
say year number of students they go 92
93 94 95 96 and 92 there was X and 1552
12:38 1459 and 1351 the table above
shows student enrollment in Western High
School from 1992 to 1996 if the median
enrollment for the five years was 1351
so this is the median this is the middle
number median and no two years have the
same enrollment what is the greatest
possible value for x so 1351 has to be
the middle number so 1351 let me make
another list 1351 has to be the middle
number and let's see what are the
numbers that we know are definitely
greater we have 14 51 and then we have
12 and then we have 15 52
15:52 and the numbers that are less we
know so this is the median we know that
12 38 is less 12 38 is less and we know
that if if 1351 is the median then X is
also going to have to be less than it
has to be there has to be two numbers
less than 13
do you want so X has to be less than
1351 so X although you know X could be
here as well doesn't it could be larger
than 12 38 so we know that X is X is
less than 13 51 and do we know that no
and it could have been equal to 13 51
but they tell us that no two years have
the same enrollment so what is the
largest possible value for x well its
1350 alright because you know what the
largest number that's less than 13 51
and then this would be 1350 here and
then 1350 one would still be the median
and we are done I'll see you in the next
section